on this the 24th of august it's game 29
for the indians
it's game 30 for the minnesota twins so
we're right there at that halfway point
line drive and a base hit to left field
for max kepler on the first pitch of the
ball game a little sinking fastball that
was running away and kepler stayed right
on it
and he swings at the first pitch as well
drives it to center
greg allen
will make the catch and back to first
goes kepler
[Applause]
swung on and missed and aaron savali
takes care of him on three pitches
popped up a breaking goal
rustling is freeman still coming in and
dropped in left field
kepler to third base
and rosario
will be held at first
does he double up nope he went to the
heater did he go yeah he did says home
plate umpire ron colbert
majeda making his sixth start of the
year his second against the indians he
faced him last on august 1st hernandez
switch intermanning left-handed hitting
275 a homer nine rbis
and it swung and it blasted deep right
center field and gone
cesar hernandez for the second day in a
row has led off the bottom of the first
with a home run
and that's only the third home run that
maeda has given up this season
and the indians have a one-nothing lead
85 a couple starts to go 115
in his last start swinging strike 3-2
down it's not at the same pace as a year
ago but they've hit 42.
swinging into miss tied him up
with a good cutter and that's strikeout
number three for aaron sivali
going back in
and that time
nailed the spot
and strikes it on that's four k's for
savali first time through the order
god i'm looking
i tell you what his
ability to just pinpoint
that fastball in away
knees that was the two
same pitch he struck out avila on
he can throw almost identical any of his
pitches any at any time for strikes and
i mean whether it's the curveball the
cutter the two seamer the changeout
from the stretch and the 0-2 he got him
strike three and a change-up
so maida works out of it pitch count
around 50. but fourth innings are at
progressive field and aaron savalli goes
back to work nelson cruz the batter
deep to right field and nelson cruz goes
to the opposite field
to tie the game his 11th home run of the
year
and it's one apiece
they tried to sneak to fastball by him
but nelson said no way
it's just a joy to watch
runner goes
strike three called inning over
[Applause]
one and two to reyes
[Applause]
splitter in the dirt
another strikeout
[Applause]
here's polanco oh for two he's fly to
center bounce to first
and that one a little bit he's waiting
for it so he better get to that ball in
a hurry into third base
comes a rise they're going to wave him
home santana's throw to the plate it's a
good one and he is out at the disk what
a great relay
boy that was really
smooth teamwork
as hernandez and santana were lined up
hernandez was in front of santana and he
quickly got out of the way because
santana has the cannon
and he made a perfect throw to roberto
to retire the runner at the plate what a
big play
another 3-2 to lindor
[Applause]
got him five really good innings tonight
again for kenta maeda the twins have to
go ahead and run in rosario at second
base miguelsa no scheduled batter
hit in the air right center field and
well this ball is going to be
out of here
an opposite field two run homer
for miguel stineau
and the twins now lead three to one
so the big man continues to stay hot now
on an eight-game hitting streak and a
lot of extra bass hits
allen at second lindor at first two down
carlos santana
there's a soft line drive base hit
center field that'll get a run home greg
allen will score
lindor on his way to third he's in there
standing and carlos santana with his
14th run batted in on the year third hit
of the night and it's a one-run game
here in the seventh in front meal reyes
will be the indians hitter
got him with a breaking ball
the indians get one but leave two
they've got the tying run on with nobody
out here in the eighth
got him cuomo strikes out greg allen
and then gestures towards the indians
dugout all right i believe there are
some words exchanged
taylor rogers will come on and try to
nail it down for minnesota
there it is
and he went
[Applause]
winning run at the plate santana three
for four tonight the door goes on the
pitch hit to right field and hit right
at kepler
the twins go to cleveland win the opener
another close ball game